today 24th of february i'm councillor
mark hurd chairman of morden district
council
set up for this meeting has been
designed to mitigate for covid therefore
can i ask all present to work to the
protocols agreed at council on the 2nd
of september 2021 in the interest of
member and officer safety
we are streaming this meeting live it is
also being recorded and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
please put your hand up if you to
indicate if you wish to speak i will
invite you at the appropriate time
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
please remain seated and keep your
contributions clear and concise
the sound recording of this meeting is
dependent on the correct use of
microphones please remember to turn on
your microphone to speak
and turn it off when finished
please
avoid approaching the top of the table
as the cameras there are live feeds that
are hazardous
and affect our streaming
all members are
asked to confine their preparation to
matters relevant to any agenda item any
declaration of interest should be
limited to the declaration itself
it is inappropriate to use public
meetings to make allegations against
employees or other members an official
complaint procedure exists to raise such
allegations and these procedures should
be used and the monitoring officer
should be contacted for further advice
any member that does not comply with
these requirements will be in breach of
my ruling i've noted this
i'll have this noted in the minutes for
possible future action and i will warn
them to desist if they persist i will
either adjourn the meeting or propose
that the agenda item should be dealt
with without access to the public under
the local government act 1972
if we go into private section the live
link will be cut and that member will
have denied the public having access to
the debate
and voting on the agenda item
so we move to agenda item two which is
apologies for absence
are we able to contact um miss bird for
any apologies
um yeah we have one apology from
councillor bell
councillor bell that is noted thank you
agenda item three
yes councillor council stamp um yes
thank you chairman um councillor uh
michael helm has had to go downstairs to
help somebody so he is present but i'm
sure he'll pop up as soon as he's done
his duty thank you okay thank you very
much
and
yes councillor skeins
i i believe uh richard siddall
councillors little sent apologies
but okay
i'm sure thank you very much
and so you've been you've been informed
of that yeah okay thank you
thank you members
uh gender item three are minutes of the
previous meetings
um
these are found on pages seven to
eighteen it's recommended that the
minutes of the council held on the 2nd
of september 2021 are approved as a true
and accurate record these are presented
for accuracy only i so move do i have a
seconder
councillor mays thank you
any member wishes to raise any matter of
accuracy they need to indicate their
wish to speak now
councillor chana
um thank you chairman please remain
seated thank you chairman
um it's page 10 chairman and it's minute
239 and it's statement of community
involvement um adoption of
um
i i think i did try to start it at that
meeting but just to say i did make
reference actually at that meeting
regarding an officer
and regarding the work regarding the
statement of community involvement um
considered you know it was really
helpful the way it had all been dealt
with and the tables and and the
responses for members to operate and i
did name the office of the only alpine
so i do think it um german when an
officer's name perhaps is mentioned that
it would be rather nice to see it
reflected in the minute that was the
intention of drawing her good work and
name
at that time chairman thank you thank
you very much any other member
are we happy to agree these by ascent
thank you very much
um
right okay thank you um gender item 3b
pages 19 to 22 is recommended that the
minutes of the council meeting held on
the 4th of november 2021 are approved as
a true and accurate record these are
presented for accuracy only i so move do
i have a seconder excuse me councillor
mays yes please thank you
one moment please council morris
uh i have one member advising on matters
of accuracy councilor stephens
i think these uh these are already
presented uh presented in the minutes
council morris
thank you i'd just like to know how uh
the minutes don't show that a point of
order was called
maybe a hundred times and the um
minutes don't even reflect that
a point of order was called once
um i was just wondering if the minute
taker has got chaneritis
um this
this has uh it is going to be replaced
with councillor c morris then raise the
point of order this was not taken by the
chairman and councillor morris kept
repeating his point of order councillor
morris kept interrupting and other
members raised their voices
i've got a problem with the interrupting
bit because uh calling a point of order
is a right you can't interrupt by
calling a point of order it is a
member's right and the chairman needs to
deal with a point of order fourth with
as the constitution states which you did
not do chairman okay council channel
thank you chairman um could it be
minuted um regarding obviously a quite
in um detailed statement there from
councilwoman could it be maintained to
please about chandritis thank you in the
minutes
yes the minutes uh the minutes note that
um councillor thompson
uh thank you chairman as regarding the
point of order and that correction
sounded as if you heard what the point
of order was and wouldn't address it in
fact we were never told what the point
of order was and it is the members jobs
rather than the members of your brothers
and the chairman's to actually indicate
what the point of order is not the
chairman's to find out as as i realize
you know chairman okay councilman i'll
allow you to come back thank you when a
point of order is called is for the
chairman to stop the meeting
at the point of order the chairman
refused to hear the point of order and
actually turned down the point of order
if the chairman had accepted the point
of order i would have given the point of
order
but i was not allowed the point of order
and there is no discretion in that in
the council constitution so mr chairman
that was your fault
right does any other member wish to
raise on a matter of accuracy
no can we agree those by a cent
what your clarification
would the chamber like to know what the
point of order was no it was agreed
great yeah we now move on to item 3c on
pages
23-26 is recommended that the minutes of
the council meeting held on the 16th of
december 2021 are approved as a true and
accurate record
these are presented for accuracy only do
i have a second
council of maze thank you
members can these be agreed by a cent
thank you very much
3d we now move to item 3d pages 27-32
it is recommended that the minutes of
the extraordinary council meeting held
on the 18th of january 2022 are approved
as a true and accurate record these are
presented for accuracy only i so move do
i have a seconder
counselor maze thank you
um
members can these be agreed by ascent
thank you very much
we move on now to agenda item four which
is declarations of interest
this is to disclose the existence and
nature of any disposable pecuniary
interests other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting
the local government finance act 1992
section 106
any members affected by section 106
please note that any declarations to
that effect should be made on the
commencement of the meeting or
immediately on arrival
under section 106 a member who has not
paid an amount
due in respect of their council tax for
at least two months after it became
payable is precluded from voting on any
matters affecting the level of council
tax
or the arrangements for administering
the council tax
the member is however entitled to speak
so do we have any uh declarations of
interest council stamp
um yes thank you chairman just a normal
i'm a member of essex county council and
i can't think there's anything coming on
the agendas that i've gone through
and
that is gone any interest on it so
chairman but if there is i will draw it
to your attention at the time
thank you very much councillor darren
thank you chairman a non-pecuniary
interest as a member of essex county
council but actually uh essex county
council are the main beneficiaries of
council tax so i suspect that is
relevant
thank you and uh councillor mays
thank you mr chairman uh non-pecuniary
interest uh item 5c fees and charges as
on secretary for malden and heybridge
heritage harbour and for the brent trust
thank you thank you cancer councillor
luca
i'll give way to mrs fleming because for
fleming
thank you councillor fluco uh thank you
chair as a member of our sixth county
council any matter relating on the
agenda thank you
thank you very much council fluker thank
you chairman uh item 13 uh given my
involvement with several smes in the
district now working train regarding
this policy
uh i will leave the chamber at the start
of this item and not return thank you
thank you i will also declare a
non-binary interest on 5c fees and
charges
as i am a trustee
for the
uh the brent steen tug trust uh council
morris
thank you mr chairman i won't be voting
on anything to do with the council tax
um i'd just like to state that uh
council tax is unlawful and under the
local government finance act of 1992
no mandatory obligation okay to make
payments
there is no point in mandatory
are a matter of stating fact not
religion any excuses for not paying
attention it's not excuses it's facts
what is your declaration um what do you
wish to declare the local government
finance act of 1992 evidences no
mandatory obligation to make payment
towards council tax
the council is under a legal obligation
to prove the people are under
obligation to comply
with the legislation which they cannot
cancel tax is unlawful thank you
and if anyone wants to chat about it or
be the uh
legislation supply it
um non-procurement are interested in uh
gender item 5c because i'm also a member
of malden average heritage harbor
association thank you councillor white
uh thank you mr miller to declare an
interest in agenda item 13 that i run a
small business and i will listen to the
debate but i won't vote on it
thank you cancer duik
chairman general item 13 as a recipient
of non-domestic rate rebate i will leave
the room for that item thank you thank
you thank you very impressed i believe
thank you thank you council stamp
am i allowed to ask a question if there
is anybody in this room that
is in council tax there is
um is that allowed can that be answered
by the monitoring officer please
i'll refer to the monitoring officer
okay i'll just double check um
i mean it has sorry to interrupt you um
miss holmes but it has been mentioned
before when i've attended a meeting
because i think it's happened previously
um with other councillors and i think it
was mentioned there i could be wrong but
i think it's really important that if
there is anybody um it should be stated
for the minutes
okay councilor morris
thank you chairman i'd just like to say
that i am in council tax arrears but
when wendy stamp's husband pays me for
the tv knockout hopefully i'll be able
to uh sort it i'm sorry
i'd like it noted that's an allegation
please and i'd like that admitted to it
he admitted to it
to note that
the minutes are noting the allegation
that you've made
it's not an allegation it's an admitted
fact
right uh
can i just clarify something um it5c
should be 9c 9c yes sorry for so for my
declaration is 9c not 5.
and the same for you ok thank you very
much
right
agenda item number 5 public questions
we have not been notified of any
the next one is public questions
the the next questions
please sit down sir you have not you
have not uh
okay all right thank you we now move on
to agenda item six
uh and i do have the following
announcement
i'd like to highlight the work
undertaken by the council because of the
recent storms eunice and franklin on
friday the 18th of february a red
weather warning was issued covering the
malden district offices immediately
updated our business continuities plans
to reflect the increased risk
contacted staff and key partners making
operational decisions such as closing
cemeteries and the council offices for
the day
throughout the storms our website and
social media channels are updated giving
the public up-to-date advice and
information
during the period covered 18 19 and 20th
of february officers responded to calls
for help either responding directly or
passing calls to the appropriate agency
several visits were made to properties
by our building control team looking at
reported dangerous structures
our parks team dealt with a range of
business issues including fallen trees
in parks and cemeteries collapsed fences
walls flood risk and damage to the
burnham town pontoon
the council also gave assistance to
residents without power working in
partnership with essex county council
emergency planning team and uk power
networks
our community engagement team made home
visits to check on vulnerable persons in
one specific case officers assisted a
care home to become reconnected to the
power supply through reporting and
highlighting concerns for residents i am
pleased the council was able to respond
to this emergency and i would like to
thank all involved
in the response for their work over the
last few days
who came together at short notice as one
team to respond
agenda right councilor morris
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
bring to the council's attention that a
homeless person um appealed to this
council for assistance before these
storms when these storms were
forecast and was basically given a tent
in two red alert
high wind weather storms
we gave out a tent to a homeless person
which is completely inadequate thank you
councillor stevens
point of order i notice sir richard
holmes is laughing at that
i just saw him laughing
thank you chair you might want to wait
and i'll come to it if you want to
finish this point first i don't know if
you've anything the point is finished
you're finished okay i just wanted to go
back to public questions because i had
this idea that somebody at the back
there couldn't actually hear what you
were saying and they seemed to be
indicating that they had submitted a
public question in advance which might
be wrong it just was what i i felt was
happening
um miss bird are you are you with us
just a second thank you
you didn't have the prophecy to take the
question
council morris whilst we're waiting
chairman the point of clarification um
is it would be your gift to allow this
gentleman to ask a question so it is
within your gift to allow it yeah it is
within my gift thank you
tara have we had any notifications
i will i will hear the question thank
you
thank you
which ones you know this young ladies
thank you very much
just to give you a quick um who i am
i'm bert cottle i used to be a uh parish
councillor for um biliricky
and um
wendy um i met wendy at um one of the
essex
council meetings and i think she could
vouch for me for being
very uh truthful and honest and uh
respectful
um my question is um about the budget
um what concerned me um
is that uh
things that have been put in print
about the people that came to
a meeting or so ago
that there was violence
or um
against uh councillors
could i ask what your question is the
question is about the budget
um
the non-disclosure agreement that
account that the councillors agreed to
um yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry could you
put it in the form of a question
yeah what is your question just coming
to that
why why the need for
um a non-disclosure agreement to be
issued to um
people that work for the council
why the need for that and does it come
out of
count
council tax budget
well what what we'll do is we have uh
we've we have that question uh i'm sure
that will be handled by uh the
monitoring officer and a responsible
company so the what officer the question
will be sent to the monitoring officer
and we'll come back to you okay thank
you very much okay and if you give your
if you leave your details at the end
okay do you think the other point is
that um
uh council morris made a point of order
and no one knows what it was
i just no i know
thank you very much indeed thank you
right we now now move on to agenda item
seven uh which is the the minute book
um
item seven a performance governance and
audit committee 18th of november 2021
there is a decision to opt into the
national scheme for audit appointments
um i'll now call on uh mrs jeanette
stiltz to present them
mrs stiltz
thank you uh
mr chairman
i present the minutes of the pg and i
performance governance and audit
committee held in this chamber on the
18th of november 2021 found on pages
33-38
there is a recommendation which needs to
be approved by council and that is
minute number 388 decision to opt into
the national scheme for audit
appointments page
36. can i have a second up for this
thank you councilman
thank you
is everybody happy to accept that
recommendation very good
mr chairman i put the minutes of that
meeting to this council can i have a
second of those minutes
twenty council
can the minutes be agreed by a scent
great thank you
okay
council seals
yeah okay thank you very much thank you
right okay move to 7b strategy and
resources committee meeting on the 6th
of january 2022.
um i call on um
well richard siddall isn't present so
will you be doing
councillor swain
council swain to present these please
oh yes thank you
thank you chairman um yes i i remembered
i moved the minutes of the strategy and
resources committee
on 6th of january
um
and uh
brought two members of attention
to um recommendations in that
one minute four two six concerns the pay
policy statement for 2022-23
for um agreement the second is minute
four to eight
on discretionary fees and charges for
2022-23
this one is only for noting as the
um the the topic comes up later under
the
uh consideration of the um
the budget
papers
so can i have a second up of the minutes
and the recommendations councillor
shawnee thank you
uh can we agree the minutes of that
meeting please
thank you members um
i can't relate it to it 13. i can't
relate it to any other number
but it is i understood that it wasn't
the job of the council to approve the
minutes
of a committee meeting
not to approve but they are to note
no they they
i
that it was
the proposal was to accept the minutes
i'm sorry
can i move
asking members to agree
are you happy with that counselor boys
no uh i'm sorry chairman um
we we cannot agree to meet the minutes
of the meeting because that is for the
committee meeting at its next meeting to
agree
not for us to agree
yeah well i think i think we're i think
we can note and then return them yes
okay so we members are you happy to note
are you happy to note these meetings
and uh they can go back to um to be
agreed
does that apply to the one paid policy
statement which i
assumed was for actual approval at this
meeting
chairman that's a recommendation
which we which we can approve yes we can
agree the recommendation not the minutes
yes that is great okay i'll go on to the
strategy resources committee meeting on
the third of february
um
and
i'll come back to you on that one i'm
going to move to um
performance governance and audit on the
13th of january
7c
um
and i call on councillor jeanette stiltz
to present them
thank you mr chairman
uh i present to you the minutes of the
performance governance and audit
committee held on the 13th of january
2022 found on pages 73-76
i ask for their adoption can i have a
second a place they can be noted i think
yes
yeah
sorry was that councillor fleming was it
yeah thank you councillor fleming i said
move
thank you happy to agree those by
having to note those thank you
okay uh
7d strategy and resources committee
third of february 2022
uh i call on councillor chris wayne to
present the recommendations coming from
councillor swain
thank you chairman and yes i've
move the um
minutes of the
strategy resources committee meeting on
the third of february 2022
um
and present following recommendations
that come forward from that meeting held
in the chamber on the 3rd of february
the first is the review of memorials in
cemeteries parks and open spaces
which
included
following recommendations
that the sale of benches as an
individual item available for purchase
which are then installed in our parks
and open spaces
cease
let a new scheme be introduced where
customers can lease a plaque on a bench
for a ten year periods
that the updated memorials and
cemeteries parks and open spaces policy
which was attached
as appendix one
um be agreed and implemented no led to
the first of april 2022
and that the new scheme be introduced
with effect from first of april 2022 and
will not be applied retrospectively
can i have a second up for the
recommendation chancellor shaunicy thank
you
can we agree the um these minutes
recommendations by ascent please
councillors
yeah i just like it noted as it was in
the meeting that i don't agree to
all of these recommendations um and the
the reasons for that are detailed in
strategy resources recording so i don't
um
i descent to these recommendations okay
that is noted thank you very much and
counselor bill
thank you chairman i'm looking at the uh
agenda here and there's no 7d
it goes 7c 7e
so where is seven delta
seven d strategy and resources committee
well not third of february you haven't
got it have you got it
well it's not showing up on our screens
anyway
right thank you
thank you councillor swain
so that is the first one uh the lease
agreement
um i think
the members have it in front of them
um
the recommendations
this is to do with the lease agreement
yeah
the um
second item on that under that
particular committee um concerned at
least agreement um which recommended the
director of service to university
um it was past exactly we asked for this
director of service delivery
leaving clarification relations to
clause 16 and 19 of the lease
um subject to one above the council
agrees a new lease for 30 years for the
organization outlined in the report
that in consultation with the chairman
of the strategy resources committee the
director of service delivery be given
authority to agree the annual rent
figure in line with current market
valuation with annual retail price index
adjustment
um can i have a second up for that
please
counselor counselor fluker thank you
i think this can be agreed by a saint
now
thank you very much
and there were a number of
recommendations in there which um
will be covered by the later budget
papers okay happy to know that members
thank you thank you very much i moved
now to seven e joint standards committee
uh and asked that councilor mark
bassinger present the recommendations
coming forward councillor bassinger
thank you mr chairman
mr swain your microphone's still on
thank you
i present the following recommendation
coming forward from the joint standards
committee meeting held in this chamber
on the 8th of february 2022
the recommendation
that the council adopt the model code of
conduct attached as appendix 1 version
of may 2021
together with the amendment resolved at
the joint standards committee on the 8th
of february 2022 to include or
well-being in appendix b paragraph 9 a
of the code and that the code take
effect by the first of november 2022
unless brought into effect prior by the
monitoring officer depending on when
essex county council bring into effect
the new code of conduct
can i have a second
council fleming thank you
can we agree uh that by a sect
sorry from council morris uh yeah i've
got i'm gonna dissent on that one um
anything that comes up with a double
standards committee now i'm gonna be
dissenting on thank you thank you um
agenda item eight are minutes of the
meetings of the council
and i propose that we note these do i
have a seconder
councillor maze thank you
this is the central planning committee
southeastern planning committee district
planning committee overview and scrutiny
central area planning committee and
north west can these be noted by a cent
thank you very much
we now move on to agenda item nine
budget and medium term financial
strategy
members
attention is drawn to procedure rule
13-5 that sets out the requirement for
any vote taken at budget decision
meeting as defined by the local
government finance act
1992 to be recorded in the minutes
this although this applies to items 9e
and 9f
it may well be that we'll take these on
block
member's attention is also drawn to
procedure rule 113a that sets out the
time limits in relation to the budget
speech and details the requirements for
making alternative proposal or amendment
as part of the budget and council tax
setting
leader please make your budget statement
chairman do you want me to stand or see
no i'm happy for you to see it thank you
very much chairman
members also chairman members and
officers
the financial year of 2021 22 has been a
challenging one for malden district
council again impacted by the coverage
pandemic but one in which much has been
achieved the council has continued
supporting the national response the
kobe pandemic assisting the vaccination
program by provision of the malden
vaccination center delivered by the nhs
to our district council offices we
continue to support our businesses
distributing over 10 million of
government support to local businesses
to ensure that that they associated jobs
and livelihoods are protected core
services throughout the pandemic have
been maintained including maintaining
curbside collection of waste and
recycling through working with our
partners suis despite challenging
operation conditions including the
national driver shortage
environmental health service whilst
meeting the increased challenges and
regulation regarding kovid ongoing
delivery of customer engagement and
service delivery whilst working remotely
we continued supporting the community
response to kirby we will build on the
strong partnerships formed with the
establishment of one moulding district
bringing together the public private and
community sectors to support health and
well-being in the district we adopted
our climate action strategy our home or
our future to bring about positive
change for the district the strategy was
welcomed and praised as excellent work
by the ecc's climate action commission's
chairman the modern district local
development plan is an essential
important document the ldp review has
started and the issues and options
consultation is underway and i urge
everyone to engage and respond
work continue to improve the efficiency
of the council by the process
improvement program funded through the
2021 budget
other notable achievements include
resilient ic systems meant we were not
impacted by the national log4j cyber
attack in december 2021 shortlisted for
the workplace transformation award for
our work on future ways of working
jointly secured a local digital fund bid
of 280 000 with colchester and tendering
to develop a dynamics task
a dynamics task allocation tool in line
with our ict strategy
continued in commitment to encourage
residents views using them to shape
services through running a budget survey
as part of the budget setting process
plus our annual resident and business
survey the council developed and
approved a new equality diversity and
inclusion policy with a focus on how we
can support and engage better with our
communities
in november we launched the enough is
enough campaign highlighting the recent
increase in unacceptable behaviour
towards our staff and members this has
been supported by other local
authorities we look now to move on from
these challenges but it remains we will
challenge any form of unacceptable
behavior towards the council
i recently became leader of the council
i thank those that have gone before me i
also thank all councillors and officers
for their dedication relentlessly
defending in the fight against covid
working closely with partners and
various other bodies all have applied
great effort to support and protect our
communities
we now need to march positively and
proactively forward in the recovery from
covid promotion and support of our
economy environment efficient effective
and value services are important we had
to be innovative and adopt new ways of
working during the pandemic and those
foundations can be built upon in seeking
further improvements in the delivery of
accessible cost-effective services
we need to do the right things continue
to be a council that is focused on its
residents services need to support
people it matters for them we need to be
responsible people need to have
confidence in our council our ability to
deliver
therefore budgets need to be sustainable
it is not just about balancing budgets
it is important that use the reserves is
not increasing year on year we need to
look ahead organize things consider and
take action
with the challenges of the past year it
is not totally unexpected that the
budget for the year succumbed to some
pressure there was additional budget
pressure that could not be offset
currently the forecast indicates 112 000
will be utilized from the general fund
to balance the budget
council finances may appear healthy with
the general fund reserve currently
sitting at 5.6 million however the
medium-term financial strategy says
increasing budgetary pressures in coming
years forecasting the general fund level
will slip below the minimum reserve
level of 2.6 million by 2024-25
and less action is taken this being
against a potentially worsening picture
with costs rising due to increased
inflation at 5.5 per cent regular revolu
of the mtfs will maintain their accurate
forecast
the financial settlement from government
2022-23
is a one-year settlement it includes
business rates baseline funding lower
tier services grants services grant
rural services delivery grant plus new
homes bonus with an increase to 961
960
172 pounds from 929 981
in 2021 uh 22. the rural services
delivery grant allocation remains at 32
hundred and thirty nine same as twenty
twenty one twenty two the services grant
allocation of a hundred and five
thousand six hundred and forty six is
help is to help alleviate the one point
two five percent increase in national
insurance the provisional base homeless
prevention grant is maintained at 142
320 with an additional 3690
pounds for domestic abuse news burdens
it is important to highlight that the
settlement funding assessments
calculation regarding the core spending
power of local authorities includes
council increasing council tax by five
pound per annum
during the budget setting process for
2022-23
the council's cross party finance member
working group has met on several
occasions to provide input into the
budget
i am pleased that members have had the
opportunity to work collaboratively and
share their views at these and other
meetings particularly the strategy and
resources committee part of that process
ensuring that any growth is kept to a
minimum recognizing the financial
challenges and unknowns ahead of us
however some investment was considered
right this includes some additional
staffing to ensure services have the
capacity to operate investing in our
commercial activity to bring forward
income generation and wider benefits for
the district
ensuring capacity to deliver on council
policy such as the climate action
strategy
due to the financial challenges ahead
2022 23 requirements after consolidation
focus on delivery of existing policies
and priorities as per our corporate plan
2021-23
the council will be exploring the
opportunities for the district that may
emerge from recently published leveling
up white paper
priorities will include deliver process
improvement training for staff and build
capacity for continual improvement work
across the organization review major
corporate contracts including waste and
leisure explore opportunities for closer
partnership working and shared service
opportunities with other local
authorities where they improve
efficiency enhance resilience and
capacity of the individual councils
deliver a customer access strategy
linking with the icc strategy and
process improvement framework and
demonstrating how we will support our
customers offline deliver an updated
commercial strategy seeking to increase
council income through an approach that
brings together our strategy and
commercial objectives
tourism is a key driver for our local
economy and the council can help to
create opportunities for further growth
and prosperity focusing again on our
tourism offer now restrictions are
lifting
all members need to be kept informed
engaged with so enabling greater
understanding and sound decision making
officers have been charged to prepare
briefings on initially commercial
projects and the leveling up white paper
constant challenge remains to ensure
best value services and deal with the
need for financial sustainability whilst
acknowledging the pressures that
households are also facing
bearing in mind our financial pressures
and the need for financial
sustainability we are proposing that
malden districts council bandy council
tax is increased by five pounds for 2022
to 23 this equates to 42 people per
month for a bandy property whilst
bringing in this increase we note that
government has recognized the pressures
currently facing both councils and
residents and has introduced a 150 pound
refund for those in banned a to d
properties as well as allocating money
for a discretionary fund
the council tax rise of five pound
equates to approximately 10 p a week
the council continues to be impacted by
the cost of covid
inflation is now at 5.5 percent council
tax increase is well below at 2.41
and commercial activities being
developed to generate income
the council is the guardian of the
public purse and needs to spend wisely
to ensure our residents know how we
perform if services are efficient
effective and best value
do we deliver on our priorities
officers are charged to prepare an
easily readable understandable annual
report for them
i thank mr chris leslie the director of
resources and his team for all the hard
work they have done regarding the budget
chairman i commend the budget to this
council
thank you leader um there is now an
opportunity for the leader of the
opposition to respond uh as he's not
here uh did you have a response
councillor stilts
thank you mr chairman um i am pleased
that the leader of the council has uh
acknowledged the hard work that has been
put into
this year and subsequent years with the
kovid
um problems that we've had i also like
to commend to the um leader that this
this budget
and
thank her for all the hard work that has
been put into it
thank you very much there will be an
opportunity for members to speak um to
speak later
but not right now
right a gender item
we're now going to move to a gender item
9 a
b c and d
e and f
that is the capital and investment
strategies for 20 22 23
a minimum revenue statement
2223
the treasury management strategy 2223
the discretionary fees and charges for
2223
the medium-term financial strategy
2223-2425
and the revised 2021-22 estimates the
original
2022-23 budget estimates
and council tax 2223
and the council tax
for
2022 and 23.
um do i have a seconder
councillor mays thank you
mr leslie can you please present the
report
thank you chairman i would just like to
recap on the member engagement that has
taken place this year as part of the
budget process
lacrosse party finance working group met
eight times throughout this year and
followed a work plan that was set out
right at the very beginning
the fees and charges policy went to the
s r committee in november with the
detailed fees and charges and the growth
and pressure items going to the
committee twice for consideration that's
in january and then again in february
time
an all member briefing was also held in
january as part of the presentation and
the q and a's were circulated along with
that presentation as well as an
opportunity to ask any questions
and
these reports reflect those figures
turning now to page 220 of the pack in
the medium term financial strategy
report
that's table one of that report this
details the forecast budget changes over
the next three years and shows an
increase in budget gap
next year a drawdown from the general
fund balance of 452 000 pounds is
included in the budget with this rising
to 1.6 million by 24 25 if no action is
taken and assumptions remain the same
this is despite a five pound increase in
council tax including the forecast which
i would recommend to ensure the gap does
not increase further this is an increase
of less than 42p a month representing a
2.4
increase against a current inflation
rate of 5.5 percent
in addition to the inflationary
pressures
covid has continued to have a financial
impact and we are now seeing where these
pressures are expected to continue in
the future
page 221 at paragraph 6.1 of the same
report
attempts to quantify the impact kovid
had on the council's
on
finances
ongoing basis and shows a potential
impact of seven hundred thousand pounds
uh next year that's in comparison to uh
their 452 000 pound gap of course
although the budget gap for next year
has been reduced from that projected
last february
the significant additional cost
pressures from covid inflation means
that the use of general fund reserve is
still required
on table 4
of page 222
this shows the council's projected
general fund balance based on the
funding gaps
and shows by the end of 2425 the balance
would fall below the recommended level
of 2.6 million
although the general fund balance is
historically high currently the
increasing gap and ongoing need to draw
down from it will need to be addressed
quickly
as with previous years the capital and
treasury strategy has confirmed there is
no underlying need to borrow to fund
capital expenditure and sets out how the
surplus cash is to be invested in
accordance with the prudential code and
advice from our treasury management
consultants
thank you very much are there any
questions
counselor fluker
thank you gentlemen i um
are we going to go i always get terribly
confused and and i'm pleased that no one
else is confused tonight but i did want
to uh propose a recommendation under
item nine did i just ask you to move a
bit closer to the mic thank you can you
not hear me that must be there
how lovely how lovely for you chairman
how lovely um
i said there's a lot of rough company in
here chairman i can't i don't know if
you can see them to my left um but yeah
chairman i wanted to um
make a proposal in relation to uh agenda
item nine e and paragraph two in
particular i mean i'm i'm i'm not sure
if if you you're going to go through all
of these reports and 90 and
recommendations or when's the
appropriate time to do it um but i'll be
guided by you chairman and i'm happy to
do it at the very end when you take are
you saying an amendment no chairman you
can't bring forward an amendment to the
budget but what i'm saying to you is
chairman that
my proposal does called with procedural
um
113b
and it's not a proposal to change or
amend the budget and it's something that
i have jenna spoke to 151 officer about
and he's content for me to put the
proposal thank you jim
okay would you like to do that now
yeah
okay so um
kevin with regards to um
agenda item 90 in paragraph 2 the
recommendations chairman
first of all i would just like to remind
members that to deliver this budget a
substantial drawdown on reserves will be
necessary
which over the course of the forthcoming
municipal year will amount to almost 10
thousand pounds per week
uh that is unsustainable and the section
one five one officer comments and
cautions council in his report then
unless we act soon our reserves will run
out and i think he's made that quite
clear
where our position will be in 2425 the
depletion of
reserves at this speed chairman is
neither conducive nor supportive of the
delivery of income generated through
corporate projects
and having reviewed the notes of the
corporate project working group my view
is
is that there will be no significant
income generated from corp projects for
at least 18 months
a financially weak council term will not
be in a strong position to make its case
for the retention of assets when the
inevitable mergers or local authorities
take place if we run out of reserves we
may have to emerge prematurely which
would mean place shaping would no longer
be exclusively in the hands of local
people and planning issues including the
allocation of strategic sites would be
determined by others from outside of
this district
during the taper down to that position
we will need to reduce our overheads cut
services and inevitably cut jobs
i recognize that the work of the finance
member working group and i've read their
notes and i know how difficult that is
and i'm nearly finished but believe
given the council's fiscal position the
group should be expanded to include
additional members who don't sit on the
strategy and resources committee because
this is a council-wide situation we're
in now chairman and i think it is quite
grave and i think that that should be
pushed out to allow members to put their
views forward informally within that
working group um members in my mind we
need to act now and having consulted
with the section 151 officer
i would make the following proposal i
propose to him that with immediate
effect
a full budget review is carried out by a
cross chamber cross committee working
group and that group reports back to
council with its recommendations in
spring i mean somebody suggested me
today that that could actually be a mini
budget and it may well be that's the
case but i really do think chairman at
10 000 pounds a week over the next 50
odd weeks we really do
need to get weaving so chairman amongst
all of that is my proposal and i thank
you
thank you um
leslie did you want to come back on any
of that at all
um
no i feel that's a a member decision
really
okay our members are happy to do do any
members want further clarification
counselor fluker i mean chairman and i
understand that uh um mr lee while mr
leslie said but clearly if this was
acceptable um chairman to council
obviously mr leslie would be happy to
support us i think he might better go
that far
all right could i ask you then to just
for um the benefit of the clerk to
repeat your proposal please
i chairman i propose that with immediate
effect
uh a full budget review is carried out
by a cross-chamber cross-committee
working group and that the group reports
back to council with its recommendations
in the spring thank you chairman
thank you leader
thank you jim could i just say something
to that we do actually have
an all member uh cross party if you like
we're not all member cross party working
group called the finance uh working
group um which mr levy and myself have
both referred to
um
it during our our speech
and rather like the policy planning
working group is going to open up to all
members i would make that a probable
suggestion rather than having cross
party across the chamber possibly
because as i said in my speech i have
asked officers to make sure all members
get briefed on matters and there is a
commercial projects briefing coming
forward for all members of this chamber
because i think when it does get to
important decisions having to be made
that all members need to have the same
level of understanding and indeed
engagement because to make uh very uh
serious decisions i think that's very
very important
so i i would say that we do have the
cross-party finance working group which
does i appreciate come from
strategy and resources but that is the
committee which has on its remit the
budgetary things that this has to go
through hence tonight while we have had
all the documents and recommendations
coming from that committee to this
council so i just make those points
chairman thank you
thank you um
tara is it possible to have the proposal
on screen at all please
okay
does any other member wish to speak
councillor swain
yes thank you jeremy just um
i agree to some extent with um what
council fluke was saying and um
certainly we are all in the same boat in
that we do need to
cooperate
[Music]
because of the challenges facing us
over the next year or two
made more uncertain actually in these
budget papers because mr leslie has had
to um err on the side of
um well being conservative should we say
um and um
and because there were some so many
large unknowns on both ways my qualm
about councillor fluka's um
uh idea is
really
how such a um an open
all member working group would actually
function
okay thank you um councillor edwards
next
uh just a question to mr leslie for me
um
the home
news homes bonus scheme
is that dependent on an updated local
development plan
no that's not dependent on the local
development plan it's currently based on
the number of uh new build properties uh
and also a number of new affordable
build properties uh however there's
currently a con consultation that's just
concluded recently and the scheme may
well change so we're still waiting for
details of a new scheme and how that may
operate thank you i actually was reading
up about it and the new scheme doesn't
does state
that it has to have an updated local
development plan
to participate in that new home scheme
thank you
so daryl
thank you very much chairman chairman uh
i i
acknowledge what counselor channel or
the leader has said but
and i agree with councillor fluker in
actual fact i actually don't think that
he's suggesting that
everybody is involved in this i think
what he's suggesting is that it should
be just wider than members of strategy
and resources so it needs to be
cross-party but the members of strategy
and resources
is it that there are representatives
from all elements of of the council but
i think that he's quite right in that
so that there is a wider appreciation
there should be members from other
committees it's certainly not something
for every member to get involved in but
i think chairman the importance as
councillor fluker has mentioned
is the fact that it's vitally important
that this authority gets on a sound
financial footing
because we are all aware of what was in
the leveling up white paper and the
final part of that involved potential
reorganization it's too early to predict
exactly how that reorganization of local
government will fall but the discussions
are already underway and as councillor
fuku says very eloquently you know if if
if we have burned all of our reserves
and effectively burned all of our boats
we are not going to be in a strong
position when it comes to negotiating
whatever
format the new local government
environment is thank you
thank you um i will come back to council
fluker but councillor lagan is next
yeah thanks chair and
i find myself in agreement with the
leader of the council i mean i i don't
see why
we need to expand out when we've got the
remit that's established anyway within
that committee um
i think we should have less bureaucracy
less process we should we've got
professional officers
who've done an extremely good job
bringing this to us what we need is some
of the assets and the aspects of the
council that we can
sell bring forward make decent
commercial decisions to shore up the
services going forward so i think that
we've actually got enough in here but we
should look within that committee
looking at other things to to be able to
realize the the cash from from assets
like this building
that can be used to bolster up the the
finances going forward to the future
thank you okay thank you
um
councillor thompson
thank you chairman um
i do hear what counselor fluke is saying
and you know i agree with our prospects
we've got to push the commercial side
forward
um
but i don't agree that we should have
anything that gets too unwieldy i mean
uh after all i'm not being entirely
flippant when i say if every member did
everything we could
dispense with all the committees do
everything at council and invest in a
decent sleeping bag because it's
um
we have got all member briefings coming
up specifically on corporate projects
and also on the budget so obviously i
would urge all members with an interest
in these things to
to attend in fact all members to attend
um and i think as the
planning policy working group has
um invited other members
i would
recommend i would commend to the working
group and snr that we do in fact
perhaps invite some other people um
invite those who are keen to come
okay but um it is um i think council
logan said and the leader said it you
know the terms of reference
are of these matters are do sit with s
and r and um i think strategy and
resources should
dealing with it through the working
group who obviously are not decision
making but give recommendations to snl
thank you chair thank you cancer stamp
yeah thank you chairman um i'm in
agreement with the leader and i think
she's demonstrated tonight by her speech
that she's continuing the cross party
and the working together that was
introduced
previously when i was the leader and i
think it's really important that we
continue to do that
i totally take on board what counselor
fluke has said and i do agree with them
to a certain extent
but i don't agree with him on this i
think that um
like what uh the leaders turned around
and said we are opening it up to all
members when we get to a certain stage
when a lot of the hard and the grafton
the discussions have been and then every
opportunity is given to councillors when
we open it up
obviously may will change the working
groups and the committees will change in
may anyway
and i think we should leave it as it is
and then the new if we've got new
members on those committees or new
chairs or whatever and then maybe look
at it in six months again but at the
moment i think what the leaders said is
very commendable and i totally agree uh
with her um rather than councillor
fluker tonight thank you chair okay
thank you council fluger did you want to
come back on any of that yeah thank you
very much sherman i mean look this this
recommendation is in two parts and and i
mean i i take enormous comfort in what
the deputy leader said when she just
said that the finance member and working
group could invite other members onto it
my um
my concern about this chairman is is
that just by virtue of our own
constitution some members are excluded
from sitting on this working group and
not because they're not on strategy and
resources but because they sit on for
example overview and scrutiny and if
you're on overview and scrutiny then you
can't sit on strategy and resources now
i know
that there are people that are on
overview and scrutiny committee chairman
for example my friend sitting next to me
who has an enormous amount of experience
with local government finance and i know
other people that are on that committee
that could bring forward
their own skill set in relation to
business and this is why i would like to
see this group expanded out
the other thing german is this is all to
do with bringing a a recommendation uh
back in the spring now i hear that
what council stamps says about hard work
discussions have already taken place by
the time
that that
working group reports back but she was
talking about six months german and as
things stand at the moment by the time
we get six months that'll be a quarter
of a million pounds gone from our
reserves now i'm not happy to wait i
mean i hear what councilman lagan says
but
for some bizarre reason the asset
management working group disappeared off
the agenda i was told chairman that the
corporate projects working group had
picked up the work of that working group
but when you look at the notes from that
working group they haven't really done
that at all so i i know mr holmes has
agreed
with strategy and resources to
reopen that working group but you know
we need to get a move on chairman
because as i said in six months time
that's a quarter of a million quid gone
out the bank and i think we should throw
this open i'm not suggesting that it is
for everybody i like the fact that the
deputy leader is saying perhaps the
finance member working group could be
you know they could expense spend it out
for another couple of of uh members to
join it you know i'm talking i'm not
talking about an unruly working group
i'm just talking about how do we get out
of this mess i mean you know look
24 25
we've got a 1.5 million pound funding
gap we need to act now if we don't act
now it could be more than 1.5 million i
spoke to quite an experienced member
today who said to me oh it's never as
bad as what the 151 officer predicts
well if it's not as bad as 1.5 even if
it's a million quid that's a lot of
money chairman and it leaves this it
leaves this local authority for which we
are all responsible for
the money isn't ours it belongs to our
residents
we need chairman we need chairman to
act and act quickly thank you chairman
thank you that's it
um
leader
um thank you chairman uh i've heard
within tell what counselor fluke has
said and i can see where he may be
coming from
however he's saying it's found and
people coming from across the chamber
and he's saying that people don't that
don't sit on snr um form the working
group well that's like every other
working group in various committees i
think what we're saying is people could
be invited to the working group because
council what perhaps our flu quiz
inventing to set up is exactly that
really a working group with a rider
remit but the working group from finance
could be opened up as the policy
planning is
to all members what i would say is
council fluke referred to a mess that
we're in i would like to say i'm aware
the finance working group actually on
the number of occasions they've met did
a lot of hard work and in fact the
budget gap was brought down so
significantly and substantially by the
work that they did it started off with a
much higher amount than we might be
seeing now so i really do feel i want i
pay tribute to the finance working group
in my speech
i did say council flank fluke i hope i
made it clear about actions needing to
come forward and move i hope behind my
message that was clear what this
authority needs to do and that is why i
have asked officers to ensure all
members are briefed and i do believe all
members should be briefed on certain
things the
commercial projects that's going to be
very interesting the leveling up white
paper and that has to do with the budget
because all me and members need to have
that comprehension when we get a report
come into this chamber for whatever
major decisions we need to make in the
future and that's where i stand and i
would like to pay regard to the strategy
and resources committee as well that is
um cross party
and that um
is another committee that has done a lot
of work as has pga so i'm not leaving
out um councillor stilts but i do think
we do need to follow our governance on
this and why do we want another working
group when we've already got one we're
just adding again and i have already
asked for working groups to be reviewed
and a review of working groups will be
happening because actually i am
do have some concerns about um reporting
back
and ensuring that things are done in the
chamber and not decisions being made um
elsewhere thank you
thank you council swain
um thank you
chairman yes um
i think there's a case for expanding the
workshops inviting
or
allowing additional people to
participate in the working groups but
what council fluco seems to be
advocating is a completely ad hoc
um
activity quite outside our committee
working group arrangements
um and that
doesn't seem right
council voice
um chairman um i i wonder whether
there's a a compromise here because i
think
everybody is on on the same side
on this
um the leader i believe or the deputy
leader
made reference to expanding the
financial uh working working group to
members outside of strategy and
resources and i'm sure i i would ask
that council fluke perhaps
if the leader would confirm this
and i'd ask councillor fluker to
withdraw his um proposal
with the support of his second
cancer fluker
well chairman
i really like before i can do anything i
need to we need to have some kind of
clarity whether or not the finance
member working group can be expanded but
we mustn't lose sight of the fact it's
all about this is all about bringing a
recommendation back as quickly as
possible german uh in in the spring
because the clock is ticking so i mean i
i'm i'm i'm waiting for the for the
leader or the deputy leader to clarify
but i would have thought chairman and
the irony of the fact that i'm on
strategy and resources isn't lost on me
but i'm not on this working group but
you know i just think gem now one or two
people in this chamber who could be an
enormous asset to that working group
chairman but at the moment they are
precluded and i don't include myself
because i am on that committee
okay i want to i want to try and wind
this this up but i want to go to uh
cancer stamp again i know thank you
chairman thank you for coming back i
think it's it's a different matter i
mean councillor fluke is actually asking
to change to change terms of references
and that needs to be done separately
tonight i think we should ask mr dodson
if if it's allowed that somebody from
somebody else can go on the finance
working group and that hasn't already
been agreed or nominated at the statutes
annual meeting
and i think that could maybe be done in
may um you're only talking about a
couple of months it's not that long is
it so why why can't the the officers
look at revising the terms of the the
committees or the the finance working
group council uh councillor johnson mr
dodson and do it that way and then
councillor fluka it's only two months
before they set up now and and to be
fair to be fair
we are in this position i mean we've had
a conservative government um
leadership
for such a long time not government
please have forgive me at this council
so two more more months waiting is is
not going to make a lot of difference is
it chairman
okay casa thompson
thank you chairman having had a very
brief consultation with the leader i can
confirm to councillor fluker that the
idea is that yes we would have
all member workshops and then all
interested members can attend and i
would encourage everybody to attend
if we don't mess about with the terms of
reference of the working group and of
snr then we don't get any into any
problems with the
constitution although i must set my own
view that the rules about
which combination of committees you can
sit on should probably be looked at but
i can confirm that the leader does
certainly propose in very short order to
hold workshops um where all members can
give their views and put them forward
their ideas
uh so if he would be
prepared to consider withdrawing his
proposal um we can reassure him on that
okay i'll allow you one more council
advice uh well um i'm sorry chairman but
it just seems that i was misunderstood
um
and i'll make the point that council is
sovereign so uh
councillor stamp doesn't need to refer
to mr dodson if the council decides it
wants to do something the council can do
it okay
and
the working group
the membership of the working group was
what i was proposing be expanded
or ask the leader for confirmation that
it could be expanded outside of strategy
and resources
what count what the deputy leader was
referring to
was workshops for all members
and the other issue that councillor
fluker has highlighted is the need for
it to start tomorrow
not
uh with due reform
deference to
uh mrs stamp
uh uh may right okay he's more than two
months away i think all right um
councillor fluker haven't having
listened to the discussion um
um
do you still want to pursue your
proposal
i was rather hoping that the leader was
going to seed and even if she just says
that it will go back to uh you know to
the finance member working group and and
so for example expanding we're only
talking about one or two people trying
to get the right people in the room it's
to support them it's the future of this
council and to delay it any longer
chairman and this is why i brought this
forward to make sure that we get
something back to this council in the
spring
i think i think she's saying that but uh
leader us
i thought that's what i was saying
actually i i could imagine that the well
more than imagine but there's a mem what
i'm saying is the member finance working
group what council fluke is actually
saying we're going to have a similar
working group set up with everyone
no to a degree across the council
um yeah you are counselor focus you're
saying to look at thing do like a mini
budget possibly and bring that forward
that should be charged in my view to the
finance working with the currently has
membership but there could be
invitations i'm sure that could allow
that to be broadened up and that would
be like the member working ship to look
at it because i think other members
should have the opportunity to be
invited to it
if i could come back
it's like to hear what council skins has
got to say but he hasn't spoken yet uh
i'll just say that we've listened to
this debate for quite a while now and i
personally feel that we should move to
the votes on it i don't think there's
much more that needs to be discussed and
secondly uh with uh concern with
councillor beal and the fact that it's
cold here any objection to closing this
window
thank you
all right council fluke
thank you chairman thank you chairman
i'm i think we've moved on slightly
further than perhaps where the leader
thought we were because i thought that
you know we were moving towards
withdrawing my proposal on the
understanding that the working group
could be expanded by a couple of members
i see them both gem for the benefit of
the camera and the tape i see them both
nodding and i take great comfort in that
but i think the thing is and i think
that the chairman of snr or the or the
vice chairman uh you know needs to take
on board that this is urgent and we need
to bring something back in the spring
chairman if the leader is content to
move that forward counselor boyce is
quite sure you know that we are
sovereign and we can make that decision
and after all we're not trying to be
difficult we're trying to get to the
position to bring some strength back
into the council fiscally which we
desperately need to do so on that
chairman i i will withdraw my
recommendation
okay and counselor second second
right
okay
right okay members so then we go back to
um items nine a to nine e
um and are there any other questions on
those
no right
okay uh
what i'm going to do is uh we are
required to have a recorded vote for e
and f however i'm prepared to take them
all on block uh and do a recorded vote
on those so um
that's amazing are you able to take i
know oh tara are you able to she said oh
yes of course you're with us now
good to see you
okay so are you um are you able to take
a recorded vote now please
you cancel
it i saw it i'm not i'm suicidal did
anyone else hear it
yeah four please four
four
oh
[Music]
four
four
four
four
three
four
four
much
thank you tara okay that is uh that is
agreed then
um we are now moving on to agenda item
10 which is a notice of motion
and in accordance with notice duly given
under procedure rule four uh councillor
morris is to move the following motion
which has been duly seconded by
councillor mark bassinger
um councillor morris can you please
present your motion
thank you very much
uh the motion is that morgan district
council resolves to write an open letter
to mps john whittingdale and pretty
patel who are the districts uh that i've
i've gone off piste on the actual uh
piece of writing i did um send an email
off i'm not sure whether or not
committee services have received it but
uh whether or not that has to go in as
an amendment i'm you know uh open to uh
the chairman's uh
guidance on that one i'll start that
again
morton district council resolves to
write an open letter to mps john
wittendale and prissy patel
asking them to raise the lack of gp
access by possible parliamentary
question if necessary in our district
and inquire about emergency funding for
malden districts and any other areas
with high patient-to-doctor ratios to
assist the residents and the emergency
departments of our hospitals which are
also under strain in these medically
deprived areas
members i would
hope that
uh all of us do agree
that one of the biggest problems to our
residents one of the biggest gripes for
all of our residents
is the lack of uh appointments at the gp
surgeries in this
do you are you happy to second this
motion
mr chairman i am happy to second the
motion okay
um members questions counselor stamp
yes thank you i'm so sorry councillor
thompson was first sorry
um
thank you chairman um at the risk of
sounding flippant um i really
do want to make sure that when we vote
on this we know exactly what we're
voting on
if we had a high doctor to patient ratio
we wouldn't have a problem i think that
should probably be expressed the other
way around
high patient patient adopter yeah thank
you
it is an amendment yes it is indeed
is that amendment seconded
second
are you are you proposing that an
amendment councillor councillor boyce
if the motion before us chairman is
being changed in any way that therefore
must be an amendment yes yes
and uh
the deputy leader has proposed in my
view an amendment i don't know whether
it was seconded
but once once an amendment's been made
of course
um then the debate is on the amendment
yes
council messenger are you happy for that
amendment to be made
thank you mr chairman i'm happy for that
right okay
right um
councillor stamp next yep thank you
chairman um i'd just like to say of
course i think i'm sure everybody in
this chamber would support uh another
letter going to mr whittendale and
another amendment to
priti patel
but i'd like to also say that this
council has for many many years attended
many meetings with many discussions with
not only the uh the mp but with the the
nhs and i myself when i was the leader
attended many meetings i'm going to hand
over to
my previous my deputy which was stephen
nunn and he still attended one of those
meetings yesterday and we always bang
the drum as i'm sure that councillor
boyce has been around a long time no
disrespect but i'm sure he's been doing
it for another for a numbers amount of
years anyway
and i think it was well minuted that i
think some of the previous leaders um
was in discussions about a medical
center coming um so you know i'd like to
totally agree with the um proposal of
the motion but i also think it's
important to know that many councillors
have also
been in correspondence and every
opportunity they get to raise this
concern
has been raised and i'd like to hand
over to councillor none because he's
attended many of these sessions i i will
come to council now but i'd like to hear
from the leader first thank you um thank
you very much chairman
i i think we all can agree with the
essence of the motion
and i most certainly and you've
highlighted it uh councillor down but
i'm sure council and none will i
certainly have made representations to
the nhs and indeed obviously our mps and
i'm sure every member in this chamber
may have
what i would like to say is though
regarding the letter what i can advise
is of course uh
john whittingdown the mp i can't speak
for pretty tell though i'm pretty sure
that's the same from what other members
have said
in my group who uh obviously do engage
with um petey patel but
mr rittingdale has already
done many of these things he's actually
um he's he's acutely aware of the
continued problems that his constituents
are experiencing and i can advise um
council morris said about asking a
question in parliament that has already
occurred in fact um he did at a meeting
in december
uh meet with the mid essex clinical
commissioning groups to discuss in full
these issues actually that the council
now has got before it and about
the action they're taking and they're
they're aware of the strength of the
feeling of the constituents as i think
mr whittingham but all our individual
constituents as well because i do know
we are making representation
and there's really um i can say about
two main elements to the current state
with the appointments and it's about
contact and booking i think which is
what councilor moyes is referring to and
also about the whole care um received
during an appointment um and he has
asked a question in december in the
house of commons to the minister who
responded regarding the telephone
systems and funding about face-to-face
meetings with um gps
it's about the telephone infrastructure
so it can encrypt actually handle the
increased demand and the secretary of
state sarah david
has also initiated a national push to
improve the telephone systems against
other things now i am aware of course
um
i think it was in december edward argher
mp that as the minister of state for
department of health and social care
that mr whittington placed those
questions there is a recording of it so
anyone can see what i'm saying and i'm
also aware um and i'm sure the the
previous leader and leaders design to
myself um would have had meetings um
liaison meetings with the mps where i'm
sure this is a very live issue
so i would like to suggest or put to
council that perhaps
we do deal with this and give updates to
members through the um
mp laser meetings because
i as a leader and the depth leader will
have those meetings and certainly this
is something that would be on the agenda
i'm aware of our officers always also
have discussions but actually i think
because mr whittingdale has done that
recently then perhaps the letter should
be framed that it's an update perhaps on
the situation the current state of play
as of now to see having placed that
questioning and being given those
answers how far that may have progressed
um by the time the letter sort of gets
to him that's what i would say bearing
mind some of those things have happened
it would be useful perhaps get the
update
from both mps
right um cancer none i'll go to next
thank you
thank you chairman uh i i mean i agree
with what's been said so far and um uh
whilst i concur that this motion is very
well meaning and is in the right
direction the public needs to be aware
that this is not a new issue this is not
something that's just come up at this
meeting that many of us in this chamber
have had correspondence with our
residents have been complaining and have
been trying to deal with this for some
time now
so this is a long-standing concern i
personally have complained both verbally
and in writing to
malden surgery uh and had exchanges with
uh with them i've also had uh verbal uh
conversations and also written uh
exchanges with the ccg
and i've also discussed this issue with
john whittingdale directly
the ccg is well aware of the concerns
that we have here in malden and as a
result they put an inspection team into
one of the surgeries recently uh to see
what they could do to address that there
are programs of intervention there's a
program of support including financial
support which the ccg
are working with the surgery on um and i
agree with the leader that this has been
already raised in the house uh by the mp
so i concur with the leader and i would
second the leaders
proposal uh when we get to that stage
that actually what we want is an update
from the mp on the actions that have
been taken as opposed to
um starting from scratch
okay thank you councillor durham
yeah thank you um as has already been
said by the leader and councillor stan
and others this this has been a major
issue for as long as i've been around
for many many years we have been trying
to
improve the both primary care and trying
to secure a new hospital for malden
i chaired for quite a long time the um
the hospital working group where we were
meeting with the nhs and providing the
ccg and nhs estates and i was actually
instrumental in walking away from that
because it was just a complete and utter
waste of time the nhs provider and all
the other stakeholders are not joined up
and we were just going nowhere and we
were wasting time i and
the mps are fully aware
of that situation and we we expressed
our
extreme frustration at the lack of
progress to secure the facilities needed
for malden which are much needed
and you know not only um in in terms of
primary care and gp provision but to get
a new hospital but we were absolutely
going nowhere dealing with the nhs
chairman is probably one of the most
frustrating and hardest operations that
there is they are i'm afraid to say
largely dysfunctional in that they don't
talk to one another we sat in meetings
in this chat in this chamber where
various arms of the nhs they hadn't even
spoken to each other since the previous
meeting so that is why we walked away
but certainly everybody in this
authority their main objective is to try
and secure better primary care and
hopefully in the fullness of time a new
hospital replacement for saint peter's
there is of course new um healthcare
facilities as part of the north american
garden suburb development and and
funding for that but absolutely it's
been top of our agenda for many many
years chairman okay thank you
and before before we take any other
other speakers i i think
i think the leader has a uh uh an
amended motion well i'm just going to
say what the amendment is i don't
haven't been seconded yet but really
based on what i've said and i've heard
what council and has said as well and
really bearing in mind the situation
isn't you and mr whittingdale i'm pretty
tell i'm sure i've done the same thing
if really what um i'm proposing is an
update letter acknowledging the work you
know and what they've found out so far
you know the current state of play
chairman on the situation and responses
through the leader mp liaison meetings
as well and that's opposite involved so
there's two tranches
um the liaison meeting should keep it
ongoing but this council could get the
update letter from both uh mr
whittingdale and pretty patel if that's
what sort
seconded
yeah we've got we're going to do we're
going to do all three
right that has so that has been that has
been seconded by council and none i've
got a number of speakers councillor
schemes next
uh yes i mean i welcome this motion i i
don't recall as discussing this in this
detail
before though of course i completely
accept that just about every member in
this council has done everything they
can to address this issue but i think
that we need to send a letter i think
that the way that this letter is written
is fine though we could add to it and
please give us an update like why on
earth would they not do that
automatically because we should be told
automatically we this is a vital thing
the more pressure we put on
the better and i don't know whether uh
mr whittingdale uh actually talked about
the problem we've got with a new
hospital here when he when he asked this
question i didn't hear the question but
i think he should be
put under some pressure to keep on
banging this drum and i think the
councillors uh messenger and council of
morris are right to bring this issue and
i support the motion okay thank you
councillor councillor boyce i know you
did have your hand up uh i think um what
what i was going to raise was that we
are actually debating uh the leaders
amendment
um
um and i just wanted to clarify but you
actually
was there in front of me for a change
uh and
um
or perhaps you read my mind
um the the issue now is we're not
debating this motion we're demating the
amendment amendment uh to this uh and an
amendment can be the
add-in or
uh
deleting
uh words yeah that's right so we need to
council morris
thank you i'd just like to say that uh
by asking for an update is all we'd be
doing is inviting to be fobbed off
um this is and
the expression beating the drum has been
used basically all of us are doing our
own little things it's more like a
little shake of the caracas
this is a big bass drum it needs a solid
message
a very clear and
concise question
to be asked of both of our parliamentary
representatives
to take this forward by parliamentary
question or not
if we allow the amendment to go through
what we're basically doing is diluting
the whole motion
yeah we might not be able to change much
in the uh
primary care the gp surgery issue
currently but it shouldn't stop us from
asking
we
must
put this forward
to show our residents that we care i
would very much
ask the other councillors to just look
at the bigger picture that the whole
council every councillor here would be
asking for better gp services for the
residents and not just an update on it
so the tories can get out of it can i go
to council messenger next please
thank you mr chairman um
i'd like to say that i you know i i
really do appreciate and i do know that
this council has and and members have
made every effort to engage with the nhs
and try and get them to uh to to uh give
us a hospital and whatever but i think
we need to look specifically at the the
one line here which is to raise the lack
of gp access
and that is something that's very
specific to the to the last two years
now it's very very difficult and i don't
understand why to see your gp and i
think we should have an update
for the previous engagements but i do
think specifically we should really ask
they need to let this go people need to
see their gps they don't need to send
pictures on their phones or phone up and
be fobbed off by a secretary or a
receptionist they need to be able to
phone up make an appointment and go back
to seeing their gps
so that is what that's what i would like
this letter to emphasize
thank you
recorded vote please chairman
yes okay all right um i think there was
another another speaker could you just
uh yeah right councillor thompson
oh
this one here chairman i'm sorry just
just a point of clarification when we're
talking about an updated letter we've
already written a letter therefore we're
sending another letter we're not
beginning at the beginning but i
absolutely hear what counselor bassinger
is saying and a lot of this is about
actual access to gps and not this phone
call business which certainly you know
in my neck of the district itself i'm
from
um
um it would actually be very helpful if
that had been kind of included as part
of the proposal because then we would
we'd have known we weren't repeating
ourselves but i absolutely take on board
what council of passengers said and i
agree with that 100 but we're still
talking about an updated letter because
we've done it before thank you
thank you cancer stevens
thank you chair well maybe i lost the
plot there slightly then because i
thought we'd just gone back to saying
let's send the letter like it is other
than the two mps and the ratio being the
other way around i think we've got to
acknowledge that there's already been
work on this otherwise we'll just get a
reply back that says well we did this in
december or whenever it was you said it
was we've got to acknowledge where we
are otherwise we'll just be sent back
thank you
and councillor swain
um yes thank you chairman um i'm a
little confused about what council what
the leader put forward seemed to be
another motion rather than an amendment
to this and therefore which only be
out of order
um unless the leader can actually amend
what we've got here to
with some phrase or other to meet her
requirements i think what she said is
another motion um i i think this one
that we've got on the agenda is
a little bit off beam actually
there is a lot and
been going on
in terms of changing the way
health care is provided a lot of new
disciplines new outstations new clinics
in different places
um in order to
try and do things in a different way
and now there are further fundamental
changes underway the ccg itself is going
to be morphed into something more um
complicated which they don't know quite
how they're going to do at the moment um
and uh they are
with a greater emphasis on prevention
um and it's going to be combining um
health care with with
health services with care in some way um
so
it's going to become even more of a um
a quagmire to deal with
having said that we all know that the
key thing has been the lack of this new
health percent health center or hub or
whatever they call it
in um in malden which would benefit the
gp practices particularly black water
blackwater
and this has been held up
not primarily by the nhs but because of
the site which is at the back end of a
development hasn't taken place or
started yet
uh and dependent partly on the south
malden um relief road which is itself
partly dependent on progress which has
been much delayed in the north aybridge
garden suddenly going off the original
motion council
the problem lies with a dependence on
developers in getting this moving
writing a letter to john whittingdale
isn't going to have any effect at all it
um it's unless he's going to get these
developers moving faster all right casa
darren
yeah thank you i think councillor swann
with the greatest respect has gone a bit
off peace there himself um i i don't see
this as being a new motion i think what
councillor um has mentioned and what
counselor passenger has mentioned i
think by amending the original motion to
include
our request that there is a pressure on
the uh primary care to resume
face-to-face
appointments because that is one of the
major concerns and that is something
that is a lot easier to rectify
we are not going to recruit new gps
overnight we are not going to build new
health facilities overnight but the the
existing gp surgeries
can
resume
their pre-covered protocols and i
absolutely think that that is a
perfectly valid amendment to that motion
and if that is done i would support it
and going back to councillor swain
again and councillor um stamp
i recall with councillor boyce
that we met with john whittingdale and
the at the time the head of the nhs i
suspect there's been seven or eight
heads of the nhs since then at three
rivers golf club during the first
examination in public of our ldp that
goes to show you how far back we were
having face-to-face meetings with the mp
and and the nhs and we got that close to
it
and it fell away but so everybody is up
to it but i'm very happy if that is an
amendment to the motion that's on the
table to resume face face-to-face uh
appointments and i'd be happy to second
and support that thank you okay uh
councillor morrison then councillor none
thank you mr chairman um i think the uh
the the appointment system is actually a
side issue because uh hybrid appoint
appointments probably would suit the uh
medical profession better if you don't
need to see the doctor but you can ask
them for something over the phone you
should be allowed to do that if you need
to see a doctor face to face you sh you
that should that is your right that
should be uh the way is what i would
like to remind the chamber is that
currently we have 1993
patients per doctor
in this district and that needs to be um
that needs to be brought down that is
one of the worst ratios in the country
as i understand it
that is the problem and the only way
through that would be extra funding
and we need to
to put our parliamentary representatives
on notice that this is what the district
wants and the council wants all right
that's what the motion is about
counsellor nun yes i can help councillor
durham with a bit more currency than the
meeting that he's talking about because
uh only yesterday councillor swain and
myself were at a meeting with the ccg
talking about exactly the same issue so
it's not just uh councillor durham and
some of these historic things that have
been occurring it's current
and the head of the ccg was there and
the head of the ccg is well aware of the
concerns that we've got here i also take
exception
to the suggestion that if we vote one
way on a motion we care
and if we vote another way on a motion
we don't care
everybody in this chamber i'm sure cares
about gp access
it's the biggest thing i have in my post
bag at the moment and i do take
exception to the suggestion that if i'm
suggesting some kind of amendment that i
don't care i do care and it needs to be
addressed but rather than starting from
scratch let's keep the wheels moving
because they're already moving
all right okay well what i'm going to do
members uh
the original motion thank you chairman
um yeah i think council voice is looking
at the emotions and i'm sure they'll
have something to say in a moment but
chairman i recognize that a lot of
what's being said particularly by
councillor dharam because i remember
these meetings but i would say to to
members don't give up because i've had a
lot of meetings lately with with the ccg
e1 which is the area that covers my ward
and the nhs and and it won't be long
before we make an announcement regarding
a new surgery in southminster and
chairman you know there's been quite a
lot of things said about dr surgeries
but i would say is i would pay tribute
to tillingham surgery i've done a
brilliant job i don't get many
complaints from them i i see my friend
nodding here and chairman eight months
ago i walked in there for a consultation
and two weeks ago i had a triple hernia
done on the national health service
thank you very much all right um members
i'm going to move now i'm going to move
now to the vote so the first of all uh
we've got two amendments and they're up
on the screen members
uh there are uh two amendments and
they're up on the screen the first
amendment which was proposed by
councillor morris and seconded by
council of bassinger is that mdc
resolves to write an open letter to mp
john whittingdale and britty patel
asking them to raise the lack of gp
awareness by possible parliamentary
question if necessary in our district
and inquire about emergency funding for
malden funding for malden district and
any other areas with high patient to
doctor ratios to assist the residents
and the emergency departments of our
hospitals which are also under strain in
these medically deprived areas that is
the first amendment that was proposed by
councillor morris
that's the motion chairman
the amendment follows that i mended the
original motion yes it was pretty patel
that was that yes i have just read out
the um the
amended motion
which will
if this if this fail members members
please
if this fails
uh then we will go for the amendment
proposed by the leader and seconded by
councillor none well can i chairman can
i just qualify that please this is this
is the motion being changed it's being
um
addressed so what we would have to be
agreeing with this new motion and then
my amendment would be on that new motion
yes
yes because but then you're going to
vote what you're saying is if then this
is granted you're not going to say my
amendment can then be voted on you are
we'll come back to my moment right
that's what you're saying okay just
unclear so we are agreeing the amendment
first of all
we're not agreeing we're not agreeing
the uh the motion we're agreeing the
amendment okay so our members happy with
the amendment in the in the center there
where the red writing is yes are you
happy with those men yes right that's
great make sense of the motion okay
right so now we're going to move on to
the amendment proposed by the leader
and that has been seconded by council
and none
and that is that the proposed letter be
updated to acknowledge the work would
and
uh
yeah the work done so
far
oh that's my place on the current
situation and responses are made through
the leader mp liaison meeting and
reporting back
um
that is are you happy with that yeah
what i meant is we could have a response
to the letter but equally the issues
could be taken up within the liaison
meeting so we've got two goes at it
and i would like to qualify within the
updated
letter there's ways that can be weaved
in about the points that celts and
bassinger made because that's all part
and parcel of the access to which um
that they're asking until their sort of
access regarding gps and that's part and
parcel of it face to face so that would
be weaved in as well right thank you so
councillor nunn are you happy with those
amendments i am chairman right in that
case i will go to the
vote on that
um can we agree that by a cent
right that is agreed then thank you
and now becomes a substantive motion
that we now have
so are we agreed on this substantive
motion this now
thank you
right okay we'll move on now to agenda
item 11.
it's a group by sent now we all agreed
yeah we we've agreed okay
i'm going to move on now to
agenda item 11 questions in accordance
with procedure rule 6 3 of which notice
has been given i'm told that there are
none
we now move to agenda item 12 the
council tax support scheme 2022-23
and
the purpose of this report is to approve
a significantly significantly unchanged
local council tax support scheme and
associated policies for 2223
with minor technical amendments as set
out in section two a to c
and there are three recommendations i'm
going to hand over to the leader
thank you very much chairman just to say
this is a significantly unchanged scheme
um supporting the delivery of large cost
neutral um scheme and i'm just can't
scroll up now let's try and do that so
there are
uh
recommendations
okay i've got it if you want you want me
to leave them out uh chairman
uh yes if you would please okay so
there's a recommendation nickel one
um that if the following changes to the
existing schemes are approved a a cost
of living increase in line with the
department of work and pension schemes
to be included in the local transport
council tracks tax support scheme for
2022 to 23 for pensioners only that any
legislative changes be introduced into
the health housing benefit scheme for
2022-23
i moved in the council's lc
lcts scheme to ensure consistency and
see minor technical amendments to ensure
that we are able to administer the
scheme reflecting current local and
national guidance there's little to
chairman that this decision has been
made following members careful reading
of and regard to the equality impact
assessment at appendix one and nickel
three that the updated exceptional
hardship fund for council tax support
framework appendix do be endorsed
chairman i don't know if an officer
wants to add any comments
do we have a second after that
councillor mays
mr leslie can you
present the report please
okay thank you chairman uh sort of
scheme is required to be approved each
year as it's been said it's uh
substantially unchanged uh from last
year there has been a decrease in the
number of people um receiving uh the
scheme from 300 300 to about three from
about three and a half thousand uh
people say reduction in the amount
um of people in receipt of that just
point out that paragraph 3.4
of the report shows the hardship scheme
is proposed to continue with the
framework there at appendix 2 and full
details of the scheme of course at
appendix 1.
thank you
members
are there any questions
can we agree that by a cent
thank you very much
we moved to agenda
answer i'm sorry uh chairman regrettably
i have to leave i'm an uh election agent
and to be at the county in we're
conditioned all right okay thank you
very much indeed
um
members
agenda item 13 updated discretionary
non
thank you
okay
right thank you members gender item 13
updated discretionary non-domestic rate
relief policy pages 337-406
the purpose of this report is for
members to approve
the updated scheme which updates and
replaces our existing policy to reflect
changes announced by central government
to support businesses
the new relief will be fully funded by
central government
leader do you wish to put the
recommendation yes chairman i will
quite simply this is just to enable
additional financial support for
eligible bridge businesses so it's out
of the recommendation of two approach
discretionary non-domestic rate belief
schema appendix one be approved do i
have a secondary yes
thank you uh counselor thompson uh mr
holmes could you uh present the report
please
or is that two is that two for uh
michelle
if it's all right
yes okay let's
so again uh another annual report that
comes through and again another policy
which is uh substantially unchanged from
last year the key point probably to note
is that this now includes the
discretionary for the covid grants as
well which have been rolled into the
annual report they're schemes that are
currently in in operation that were
approved as part of the snr committee
but for completeness these have now been
rolled into the discretionary scheme and
were ask to continue to pay
those
businesses who are eligible for release
as part of the covid scheme
thank you any questions members
happy to agree this by ascent
thank you very much
moving on now to a gender item
oh yes yes if we could have those
members back please
counselor
could you just let the other members
members if they'd like to come back
well awesome
sorry
soon
about that oh yeah
[Music]
no mark's left now okay
all right thank you thank you members
okay can we move on please agenda item
14
um taxi and private hire policy and
licensing conditions page
407-456
um the purpose of this report
is
as is in front of you
there are
two recommendations
leader are you able to uh put those
recommendations um well yes chairman uh
they're up to from what i can see
uh legal one time number two at two
paragraph two but the amendments the
licensing commission defenses two and
three be approved and that the taxi and
private fire policy appendix will be
approved thank you do i have a seconder
councillor maze thank you
um
who will be presenting this report mr
holmes is it
gentlemen there we have ms gibson on the
uh on the line she's happy to answer any
member questions but it's funny
straightforward report the uh this
matter was uh looked at by council uh on
the 2nd of september 2021 it's been out
to consultation and this is the feedback
from that consultation and the
amendments but as i said we have the
officer here to answer any member
questions thank you thank you thank you
miss gibson are you able to present your
report
yeah chairman i can't send your report
if you wish
thank you
okay and following statutory gardens
issued by the department of transport
the council agreed to draw upon the skin
conditions for an agent to taxing rabbit
higher licensing
there was a six weeks consultation from
mid-october to the end of november last
year and there was limited response to
the consultation and but there was very
little to say apart from a member of the
trade
however as these have been um
recommendations being put in place to
protect children and vulnerable adults
and these changes are required
some amendments are proposed to be
licensing conditions due to constructive
feedback from the trade
members are asked to agree the
amendments and the policy it is proposed
that these changes are implemented from
the first of april this year
thank you very much indeed uh members do
you have any any questions on this
no okay happy to agree by ascent agreed
thank you
um agenda item 15
committee meetings and future options
page four five seven to four six six
um
these are to consider the ongoing
arrangements for committee meetings in
light of changes to uh the government
restrictions uh are you able to put
these recommendations leadership
um
thank you chairman sorry about that my
computer had a weird moment my digit did
too so um regarding the recommendations
there's actually five of them chairman
that they're quite long but
one is little one the members review and
note that updated risk assessment set
out at appendix a for physical meetings
to that members extend the emergency
decision for physical public meeting
attendance subject to capacity members
as outlined in appendix a
and that three members review other
mitigations listed and confirm which of
those set out in 3.3 they would like to
procedurally continue upon consideration
of current guidance
nickel 4 that members confirm
continuation of youtube live streaming
of meetings past the removal of coverage
restrictions in light of the information
set out at section 3.8 of the report and
five chairmen that for the
non-regulatory matters to allow those
members unable to physically attend to
join remotely to ask questions engaging
debate subject to chairman approval
noting that they would not be able to
vote chairman
thank you do i have a seconder thank you
very much uh mr dodson are you able to
present this report please
yes thank you chairman um
this is a fairly straightforward report
obviously the
guidance
for the for covered guidance has been
updated it was updated at the end of
january which resulted in the emergency
decision to change the
access to the chamber for the public
um
that would need to be extended as the um
the decision lasted up until today
um when council's meeting unable to make
a decision
um the other key part of it is that
subsequently there have been further
changes to the regulations
with the removal of virtually all coded
regulations from today
the important thing i think in this
paper is that members consider the
measures previously agreed under 3.3
which they need to review in light of
those changes to the covid regulation
national covert regulations and guidance
thank you jen
thank you um
any questions members councillor
lagan yeah thank you chair as um mrs
dodson said the the government uh legal
measures ended today
so i've looked down at what the the
current register legislation guidance
says and i've got a bit of a problem
with the public to watch via youtube and
that's participating the first part i've
got no problem with i think it makes
perfect sense and we get more engagement
by having online presence um i do have a
problem where it says the risk
assessment has reviewed physical
capacity numbers based on general crowd
management and space i
can't in my profession i haven't seen
any references to what those uh
sites are um measurements actually are
and
you i don't know if this is
recommended six in the council chamber
and 25 in the northern room you could
probably get 10 in the council change
with the spaces there with the other
chairs that we used to have so i'm
uncomfortable by limiting uh public
participation actually in the chamber um
and also on the risk assessment
i just scrolled down i tell you the page
um
page 463 you know attendance by affected
persons you don't know
no mitigations that you can put in there
to limit attendance by affected person
so i question that they would actually
have any any measure at all
um
and the last one that i put in was again
it was in the risk assessment you know
it says based on an area five by five in
the northern river it cannot holiday 25
chairs you can go to a football match
pub you can go to a restaurant you can
sit next to anybody kind of tube you
haven't got that so i think those those
things i'm not prepared to support
restricting the amount of people we can
get in here the more people we get in
here the better
so
i think the report's good i think
there's
let's give it down to people's personal
responsibility um and if they want to
wear a mask and do what they want to do
that's down to them but i think we
should definitely definitely get more
people in if we can
and allow people to have mitigations if
they feel that it works for them
so that's my points on a chair thank you
i was like not a second hand
could i just uh seconded
thank you cancer schemes
yes i mean i would uh agree with that uh
we need to have
i mean this tech chamber is so badly
designed for public space for public um
presence anyway but yeah certainly more
than six we should be able to put that
back in and i just and i guess the
proposal would be
uh well i'll go back to council legging
on this but that we have as many as is
physically
possible in you know uh
within reason
uh or that we return to what we had
before i guess would be what you're
saying councillor again through the
chair yeah could i just ask you cancer
legging could you
be clear on your proposal because we
need to we need to get that um
typed out thank you yeah i think the
proposal should read and you'll have to
busk us a little bit um that members um
and officers are at liberty to to take
whatever measures they feel so fit to
protect their own um health and safety
and that the chamber should uh
accommodate as many uh members of the
public as possible um to uh observe
participate in i'm sorry we're trying to
type this down while you're saying what
is voice recognition software chair hey
hello
right is that
is that okay with you councillor
yeah i think maybe just to add a
footnote you know as as as what
councillor schemes have said as you know
as as reasonably practicable
and safely
yeah because you can't have we can't
with all due respect you can't have 100
people in here because it's just not
it's not saying it's not feasible okay
and
and working within guidance and
regulations
right
uh so that was
that was uh
proposed are you happy with that uh
councilman seconded
members are you happy to agree that
oh sorry councillor thompson
oh
sorry i'm happy to agree i was sort of
moving on i was getting ready to move on
from there chairman
happy to agree that thank you right uh
so that is uh
that is agreed
um
right where are we so we we need to go
back to the um
five recommendations
um any other questions on those members
yes yes yes council councillor thompson
thank you sorry swift thank you chairman
um a couple of things i
very strongly think we should keep the
youtube live
stream yeah yes streaming um i think
there's very little as good that's come
out of the whole covid thing but i think
this is
probably ones
because of you know everyone can't get
in the chamber everyone can't
necessarily get here for evening
meetings don't drive whatever
um must keep that
i certainly agree with the
non-regulatory matters where it's you
know fits in with statute then members
should be able to comment remotely
although we know they can't vote unless
the law changes
and the other thing is i think that the
face mask should continue to be
available to members of staff and
probably members as well
who feel they need to wear on the ffp 3
standard
um that's my own view i don't know what
other people will think but
okay
an awful lot of people now won't want to
wear one but i think you know since
we're more or less obliged to be here i
think they should be available for those
who do
okay thanks jim uh thank you so i think
those i think you're agreeing with the
the the recommendations such as we've
had but additionally that we have the
masks still available
right okay i've got a couple of
questions a couple of questions
um counselor casa stamp i know was first
sorry thank you i totally agree but can
we actually look upgrading the sound
quality i think every meeting we attend
we'll some of us get messages i can't
hear i can't hear it's usually counselor
which is a surprise that you usually
can't hear him and we all know if he'd
been here would chuckle anyway um but
can we actually look at that i don't
know as a council if we've got that
because the sound quality is very poor
in this chamber i mean sometimes i can
i'm struggling to hear counselor channel
um and i think people on youtube like i
said i'm often getting messages and said
i'll moan actually the day after can't
bloom near the council meeting there's
no point in even watching on youtube the
quality is so poor so i think if we're
still encouraging members of the public
to do that i think we need to up our
game and make sure they can hear us
right okay
um i'm sure the
sure mr holmes will note that yeah okay
that's fine
um
councillor stevens
thank you if we are going to buy masks
can we buy the right sort this time so
i'm pretty sure we bought the wrong sort
last time with
i don't know valves going out the wrong
way or something thank you yes i'm i'm
sure we will
yes councillor thompson
sorry leader sorry chairman i don't know
who to apologize to um i wasn't only
going to say yes the ones with the
bowels protect the wearer but
unfortunately if the wearer has coveted
they're not going to protect anybody
else that's just quite a clarification
and i should have said but didn't yeah i
would prefer we
use the ones that protect everybody and
don't have the vowels but obviously
we've got stock we should use them i'd
hate to see them thrown away
thank you okay um council morris thank
you mr chairman um i'm against us buying
the masks not because i'm against masks
if you want to wear one you wear one
it's personal choice it's just that i
don't know a single person in this room
that can't afford to buy their own mask
and it's not something the council
should uh have to fork out on
right okay um
i think uh i think we so we're happy to
agree those
yes council caster swain and then
councillor legend what what what would
we be um
passing or agreeing to under little
three because it says we should confirm
which of those
in three three we wish to continue with
can you help us mr dodson
um you members can either review it but
i thought
some of what councillor lagan said
covered
in general the the answer to it yeah so
unless there's anything that members
would specifically like to do over and
above i think that probably covers it
okay council again yeah sorry i
absolutely agree with cancer morris on
the masks it's
by myself
the public shouldn't pay for masks if
it's a choice matter right um members
what uh what is what is your view on
what is your
anybody have any opposing view counselor
stevens
thank you i thought we just said that we
were getting masks for the staff who
have no option as to whether they come
here or not and it really it's so cheap
it's just it just isn't an issue can we
not debate that
thank you
cancer schemes
yes so i think i hope i have
misunderstood this i thought it was
availability of mass for everybody uh i
think staff should be provided with
masks because they they have no choice
uh i think members can afford to buy
their own masks and indeed they do
and but then maybe there should be some
masks available for members of the
public so it's kind of much of the
muchness we are going to need a store of
masks so right okay our members happy to
agree that
anybody know
sorry thank you chair look
i don't want to crack on about it for
too long i think the cat the the
officers themselves have a duty care to
their employees and it's down to them to
make a determined decision whether they
want to use offer
their staff masks they can't enforce it
but they can recommend it i think for
members of the public it's an optional
thing for those is what i said yeah they
can come in and do it it's an optional
thing for us as well i don't think we
would we do by hand sanitizer do we buy
petrol do you give me a cup of tea i
think it's it's very simple and very
very quick just to say look it's
as the government
even that person he says it's personal
responsibility to take that personal
responsibility if people feel
comfortable doing it they can feel
comfortable in doing it you're not
stopping anybody but we've got to draw
the line somewhere and they're not as
cheap as you think you know so i think
we should just say you know at the end
of the day
you know if you want to come along come
along but protect yourself in a way that
you feel you need to
thank you
councillor schemes yes very quickly i
have to say i think uh councillor is
right about that okay casa swain
um are we they're dispensing with the
agreed um
regulation on one-way system for
movement around building and dispensing
with anything connected with lateral
flow tests well i think we're leaving
that to the directors are we not
are we dispensing with the one-way
systems and
that that was covered by uh again
i understand
by
what council and i can set and everybody
agreed to in principle
right
here right happy to move on members
right those are those i all agree we
move on to um
right
agenda item 16
update on social enterprise accelerator
fund and member representation pages 467
to 470.
um this is uh to
the purpose of this report is to update
members on the additional restriction
grant funded social enterprise
accelerator fund
and to consider the appointment of
member representation to an internal
awarding panel
two recommendations are you able to put
those leader yes
uh recommendation nickel one is purely
at the creation or the internal award
panel for the social enterprise
accelerators might be approved
and nipple two that the member
nomination set out in section 3.11 be
ratified and one additional member
appointment be approved for the
remainder of the reusable year and while
i'm here speaking chairman
the three names there is actually three
names already there and it's a matter of
posts as well and that is councillor
richard siddall um to be ratified who's
the chairman of um stuttering assaults
in uh councillor carly mays because she
sits on the london business forum
and myself as leader and then um there's
one more name to be done and i would
like to propose from the chair that
that'd be councillor stamp because
councilman stamp is the representative
in the burnham area
regarding business and therefore we've
got the balance across the district in
terms of north and south if you like and
wonder about malden and burnham and
that's been my proposal chairman we
ratified those three and then um i
nominated councillor stamp to be the
fourth member on that panel okay do i
have a seconder councillor maize um
thank you um
i think we have uh leander cable
yes
we do hello hello there uh could you
present the report
on the 6th of please especially
resources
for individual approaches to making
additional restrictions for our funding
for the council's climate 19 economic
recovery and transformation program
underneath the program
simple community community-focused
organizations to enhance economic social
and culturalism districts
these activities will help develop a
resilient social economy for residents
and businesses
to ensure fair and clear decision-making
and internal inspiration folks will
review an approval design applications
it is important to note that the
council's additional restrictions grant
allocation central government must be
degraded by the 31st of march 2022
thank you chair
thank you very much any questions
members
right the recommendations are that those
four those four members
um are agreed as uh the
uh to be appointed to the to that panel
is that agreed
thank you
right we now move on to
um agenda item 17.
sorry chairman just on the previous
video
yes that is agreed
right okay so we're almost almost
yes sorry counselor gentlemen can i
speak under the next agenda item before
you say you haven't got anything because
i think something's arisen tonight i'd
like to bring up i think it's important
i have got something that uh that i'm
going to to
can i say something as well please just
yes you can
do
okay this is under um
urgent business
um
i want to address the comment which was
made by councillor morris earlier in
relation to mr holmes and state that mr
holmes has sat through this meeting
wearing a mask
and that your comment counselor morris
is not to be recorded in the minutes
counselor stamp
chairman you must have read my mind i
actually wanted to go a little bit
further and i think the officers and
directors cannot respond to members
accusations
i cannot believe for one moment that the
director who's been here for many years
would show so much disrespect and i
think council morris should withdraw
that comment and apologize publicly for
saying that the director laughed about a
situation that he is responsible for
dealing with day in day out and i know
for a fact that when um the um
the we had all the trouble he was
messaging me about things in my ward at
all hours of the day and i think it is
totally unacceptable that that sort of
comment should be allowed so i think it
should be withdrawn
cass and morris are you prepared to
withdraw that remark
i'd like to speak before i answer that
question
i am sitting within spitting distance of
richard holmes and i saw him chuckle
with my own eyes now unlike yourself
chairman who refused to admit that you
heard cheering at death fret's
previous meeting okay i mean i have not
gotten channel right are you prepared
are you prepared to withdraw on your
nelly he laughed when i said when i was
speaking about a homeless person being
given a tent towards the code of conduct
that's fine
uh thank you chairman i'm going to put
words in the mouth or behind the mask of
mr holmes but i think anything in the
way of anybody chuckling and i did which
would be related to the fact that
someone who announces and chooses not to
pay council tax would complain that we
don't have the resources to help people
more than we do
i am paying council tax but i am not
prepared to pay
for employees
that we've given non-disclosure
agreements are you stating it's rubbish
well so what do you know about them
because apparently they're
non-disclosure agreements
i'm asking you to be silent and i'm
responding
to
the deputy leader when she's directing
questions i'm on my feet
oh you might be what you're stretching
your legs
i'd like to is that supposed to scare me
i would like writing in your i'd like
the minutes to note that once again
councilor morris has failed to obey a
request by the chairman an unreasonable
direction it is a direction by the
chairman
um largely
why don't you ignore this channel
thanks chairman i'd also like it
recorded in the minutes in that
statement chandritis was referred to yet
again i would like to refer to my speech
earlier tonight about enough is enough
and i'd also like to draw attention to
my speech when i spoke about equality
diversity and inclusion which covers
people with disabilities that might not
be seen
can that be recorded chairman thank you
yes i'm happy for that would you like an
explanation of channel writers at the at
the
right there's nothing here's nothing
i think gender item 18 was exclusion of
the press
and public this is to resolve that under
section 108
4 of the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following items of business on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph three of part one
of schedule 12 of the act and this
satisfies the public interest test do i
have a seconder
and maze thank you
i would like to remind members that they
should uh
if they
right okay can we make sure that the the
feed is off i'd have to ask members
you